[Music]
so effective altruism is basically
applying the scientific method and
evidence and analysis to the whole
concept of charity it's about so looking
in the world you know the world has a
gazillion problems a lot of them are
very very bad but some are easier to
solve than others some are cheaper to
solve than others and so there are some
some actions that we can take that are
more effective than others in reducing
suffering or increasing that happiness
in the world and effective altruism is
basically about identifying what are
those methods of improving the world as
quickly as possible and as effectively
as possible so there's within the
community there are sort of teams of
analysts looking at these problems and
figuring out the best interventions the
best charities that are out there and
then raising awareness of it picking a
charity is is tough and the the things
to look for I guess to start with is is
the cause area in itself neglected you
know there's there's countless different
problems in the world and some of them
are far more researched or receive a lot
more funding than others and similarly
there are some some problems that are
actually but there's just a ton more
room for funding where your money can
make a very big difference so that's the
first thing to look for if it's
neglected next thing is is the is the
act is the charity that you're going to
donate for giving you the maximum bang
for your buck will it help for most
people with per per dollar that's
donated another thing to look for is is
the problem you know so are the results
that it's likely to generate measurable
because if we can't measure what the
charity is doing more than we just don't
really know how effective it is so yeah
those are some key indicators to look
for also is is the charity transparent
now not all chair
that aren't completely transparent
doesn't mean that they're necessarily
bad but at the same time if they're
doing very sort of actionable positive
things then they should be able to
demonstrate that clearly so yeah those
those are sort of the four key points
I'd look for since starting to play
poker about ten years ago I've been so
fortunate with my results and the
opportunities that I've been given
throughout through it but after a while
it I started realizing why should
probably be doing something else with
this you know is there is there a way I
can continue playing the game that I
love but also have a more positive
impact on the world and at the same time
some friends and I met some effective
altruists who wanted to chat to us about
you know how how we you know could be
fundraise through the industry and we
after they sort of explain to me how
effective altruism works how some
charities are just hundreds of times
more effective than others and it was
the arguments was just so compelling I
was like okay how do we how do we get
involved how do we do this so we decided
to create an organization that
fundraisers for these charities called
raising for effective giving raising
because there's like play on words there
with that's what you do in poker and so
yeah we started this this organization
two and a half years ago and we
fundraise for about eight or so highly
effective charities across a number of
different cause areas we have some that
a direct suffering alleviation most of
those are in the sort of poverty sphere
we fundraise for some similarly the most
effective animal charities and a couple
of research organizations that are
looking into potential existential risks
that are likely to hopefully unlikely to
happen but if they do happen could be so
catastrophic and they're they're they're
very sort of under researched right now
so we have quite a broad spectrum of
charities that we raise for but all of
them are either highly effective or
projected
to be very effective and yeah we we
started at two and a half years ago so
far we've raised just over two million
dollars through the poker industry for
these charities and it's been an amazing
learning experience
[Music]